kalau kamu memutar bola di sekitar satu sumbu lalu sumbu lainnya hasilnya tidak sama dengan melakukan dua rotasi dalam urutan terbalik
hari ini di Qiskit in the classroom kita akan melihat apa hubungan bola ini dengan komputer kuantum dan salah satu prinsip paling terkenal
dari mekanika kuantum yaitu prinsip
ketidakpastian selamat datang di Qiskit in the classroom sebuah seri video di mana kita mengurai konsep fundamental yang mungkin kamu
temui dalam kursus terkait Quantum Computing setiap video disertai modul interaktif yang ditautkan di
deskripsi di bawah jadi pastikan kamu lihat itu hari ini kita bicara tentang prinsip ketidakpastian Heisenberg kalau
kamu pernah mendengarnya sebelumnya kamu mungkin juga pernah mendengar lelucon lama tentang Heisenberg suatu hari dia ditilang saat berkendara dan polisinya bertanya apakah
kamu tahu seberapa cepat kamu berkendara Heisenberg menjawab tidak tapi aku tahu persis di mana aku berada ini semacam
prinsip ketidakpastian Heisenberg dalam intinya kamu tidak bisa secara bersamaan mengetahui posisi dan momentum partikel
dengan presisi sempurna ini sering ditulis seperti ini Delta x dikali Delta p lebih besar dari
atau sama dengan h dibagi 2 di mana Delta X dan Delta P adalah
ketidakpastian dalam posisi dan momentum dan H adalah konstanta fundamental yang sangat kecil dalam mekanika kuantum
Heisenberg menemukan pertidaksamaan ini pada tahun 1927 ketika dia membayangkan cara mengukur posisi elektron kalau
kamu memantulkan foton dari elektron untuk melihat di mana ia berada, foton itu pasti akan menendang elektron dan mengganggu
momentumnya ini bukan hanya pernyataan tentang pengukuran yang mengganggu sistem ini memberi tahu kita bahwa ada batasan fundamental
tentang seberapa banyak yang bisa kita pelajari tentang alam ini adalah salah satu contoh dari prinsip yang lebih luas yang disebut komplementaritas yang
mengatakan bahwa aspek-aspek tertentu dari alam tidak kompatibel satu sama lain dan tidak bisa diamati
secara bersamaan misalnya objek kuantum terkadang berperilaku seperti partikel dan terkadang seperti gelombang
tapi kamu tidak bisa mengamati kedua perilaku tersebut secara bersamaan relasi posisi dan momentum Heisenberg hanya mencakup salah satu dari
banyak set fitur komplementer ketidakpastian inheren ini berkaitan dengan bagaimana kita memandang properti seperti
posisi dan momentum dalam mekanika kuantum alih-alih memikirkan X dan P sebagai variabel atau properti intrinsik
yang dimiliki setiap partikel dalam mekanika kuantum posisi dan momentum adalah operator mereka bukan properti dari
sistem tapi hal-hal yang bisa kamu lakukan pada sistem mempelajari tentang posisi partikel sekarang mengharuskan kamu untuk melakukan
operasi pada sistem tersebut dan membuat pengukuran operasi ini bisa mempengaruhi hasil operasi lain berikutnya
sebagai analogi pikirkan sepotong kayu kering ia memiliki banyak properti seperti
posisi ukuran bentuk ia juga memiliki properti bisa dibakar dan bisa mengapung di air kalau kayu ini adalah
objek kuantum ini bukan properti yang bisa kamu ketahui begitu saja sebelumnya sebaliknya kita mengatakan mereka adalah
observable hal-hal yang bisa kamu pelajari tentang sistem kalau kamu melakukan beberapa operasi padanya jadi kamu perlu menerapkan
operator kemampuan bakar atau kemampuan apung yang mengharuskan benar-benar mencoba membakar kayu atau memasukkannya ke dalam
air untuk melihat apakah ia mengapung sekarang hasil dari masing-masing operator ini bergantung pada urutan kamu menerapkannya kalau
kamu pertama-tama menguji kemampuan bakar kayu akan terbakar menjadi abu dan kamu tidak akan bisa menguji apakah ia mengapung tapi kalau kamu menguji
kemampuan apung terlebih dahulu maka kayu akan terlalu basah untuk dibakar kita mengatakan operator kemampuan bakar dan
kemampuan apung tidak komutasi urutan operasi penting ini mengarah pada batasan fundamental
seberapa baik dua observable ini bisa diketahui tentang sepotong kayu karena kita tidak bisa mengatakan dengan pasti apakah ia bisa
dibakar atau mengapung tanpa mengetahui konteks pengukuran tersebut tentu saja dengan sepotong kayu yang sebenarnya kamu
bisa memotongnya menjadi dua dan menguji kedua properti tersebut secara bersamaan tapi kamu tidak bisa melakukan sesuatu seperti itu dengan partikel kuantum ini
analogi kayu ini hanyalah analogi ketidakpastian adalah hal yang unik kuantum X dan P juga tidak komutasi
dan properti non-komutativitas inilah yang mengarah pada prinsip ketidakpastian Heisenberg secara umum dua operator mana pun
yang tidak komutasi akan memiliki prinsip ketidakpastian mereka sendiri bentuk umum dari prinsip ketidakpastian bisa
ditulis seperti ini Delta a dikali Delta
B lebih besar dari atau sama dengan
setengah kali nilai dari a dan b di mana
tanda kurung ini disebut
komutator dan itu sama dengan perbedaan antara menerapkan pertama-tama a kemudian
B dan menerapkan pertama-tama B kemudian a tanda kurung sudut
ini menandakan bahwa kamu mengambil apa yang disebut nilai ekspektasi dari apa yang ada di dalamnya pada dasarnya kalau kamu membuat pengukuran yang sama
berkali-kali nilai ekspektasi adalah nilai rata-rata dari semua pengukuran tersebut hari ini kita
akan benar-benar menguji dan memverifikasi prinsip ketidakpastian ini pada komputer kuantum IBM kita akan melihat tiga observable berbeda
dari qubit menunjukkan bahwa operator mereka tidak komutasi dan akhirnya kita akan bisa membuktikan bahwa
prinsip ketidakpastian berlaku untuk observable qubit ini pertama sebuah catatan singkat tentang cara yang membantu untuk memvisualisasikan
state kuantum dari qubit bisa direpresentasikan oleh vektor yang menunjuk ke suatu tempat pada bola yang disebut bola Bloch aku membahas
ini dalam video sebelumnya yang ditautkan di deskripsi tapi aku hanya akan memberimu rekap singkat di sini juga ini adalah
bola Bloch setiap vektor diparameterisasi oleh dua sudut Theta dan F
state nol berada di kutub utara dan state satu berada di kutub selatan dan superposisi yang sama antara 0 dan satu berada
di suatu tempat sepanjang khatulistiwa di mana f sama dengan fase relatif antara dua bagian dari
superposisi jadi state di sini akan sama
dengan 1 / akar 2 kali 0 + e pangkat i phi kali 1 di mana i adalah
fase itu ketika kita mengukur observable dari qubit hasilnya selalu salah satu dari dua pilihan yang sesuai dengan dua
state yang mungkin dari qubit untuk eksperimen yang akan kita lakukan kita akan melihat tiga observable dan
operator yang sesuai X Y dan Z ketika kamu mengukur salah satu dari observable ini kamu mendapatkan plus satu atau
minus satu dengan probabilitas untuk masing-masing yang bergantung pada sudut antara vektor qubit pada bola Bloch dan
WEBVTT
sumbu pengukuran seperti yang mungkin kamu harapkan Z mengukur sepanjang sumbu Z X sepanjang X
dan Y sepanjang Y sekarang ingat kita berbicara tentang observable karena dengan sistem kuantum
kita tidak bisa hanya mengetahui hal-hal tentang sistem tanpa mengukurnya
dan setiap observable memiliki operasi yang sesuai karena pengukuran membutuhkan operasi mungkin tidak jelas tapi
ternyata operasi yang disebut operator yang sesuai dengan masing-masing observable x y dan z ini adalah
rotasi dari Pi di sekitar sumbu masing-masing jadi X adalah rotasi di sekitar X Y
di sekitar Y dan Z di sekitar Z jadi untuk melihat apakah operator-operator ini komutasi atau tidak kita bisa memeriksa apakah rotasi
pada bola komutasi atau tidak kalau ya prinsip ketidakpastian tidak akan berlaku dan kita bisa mengetahui X Y dan Z tentang qubit
dengan presisi sempurna kalau mereka tidak komutasi maka kita akan bisa menemukan relasi ketidakpastian baru untuk qubit perhatikan
titik pada bola ini saat aku memutar pertama-tama di sekitar X dan kemudian di sekitar Y ia berakhir
di sini sekarang mari kita coba dalam urutan terbalik jadi aku memutar pertama-tama di sekitar Y dan
kemudian di sekitar X ia berakhir di sini jadi mereka pasti tidak komutasi artinya
kita tidak bisa secara bersamaan mengetahui nilai X Y dan Z yang tepat dari qubit kita akan memiliki
relasi ketidakpastian kita akan melewati detailnya tapi kita mendapatkan tiga relasi ketidakpastian yang berbeda
jadi kita punya Delta x dikali Delta Y
lebih besar dari atau sama dengan Z Delta y Delta Z lebih besar dari atau
sama dengan X dan Delta Z Delta X lebih besar dari atau sama
dengan Y jadi produk dari dua ketidakpastian mana pun selalu lebih besar dari atau
sama dengan nilai ekspektasi dari observable ketiga mari gunakan Qiskit untuk melihat apa yang
terjadi ketika kita mencoba mengukur Z dan X dari state nol mengukur Z itu mudah ini adalah basis standar yang disebut
dari komputer kuantum pengukuran selalu sepanjang Z secara default tapi untuk mengukur X kita perlu melakukan sesuatu yang disebut
perubahan basis pada dasarnya memutar bola Bloch sehingga X sekarang menunjuk ke atas di mana Z biasanya menunjuk untuk melakukan ini
kita menggunakan Hadamard gate jadi quantum circuit penuh akan terlihat seperti ini kita mengukur dalam Z menerapkan Hadamard
dan kemudian mengukur X kalau kita menggunakan Qiskit primitive sampler untuk menjalankan eksperimen ini berkali-kali kita
mendapatkan histogram dari hasil pengukuran yang terlihat seperti ini untuk pengukuran Z
dan seperti ini untuk pengukuran dalam X jadi seperti yang bisa kamu lihat kita mengukur
qubit berada dalam state nol sepanjang Z dengan kepastian yang sangat mendekati 100% tapi
sepanjang X kita pada dasarnya tidak tahu apa pun tentang state qubit itu diukur menjadi nol atau satu dengan
probabilitas yang sama artinya ketidakpastian kita dalam X hampir sebesar yang bisa ada itu memberi kita
sedikit gambaran tentang pertukaran ketidakpastian ini tapi kita bisa melakukan sedikit lebih baik pada komputer kuantum kita bisa menggunakan
Qiskit primitive yang disebut estimator untuk menemukan nilai ekspektasi dari observable kita X Y dan Z dan
ketidakpastian dalam masing-masing mari kita coba untuk state yang menunjuk dalam arah plus X pada bola Bloch kita akan menggunakan estimator
untuk menghitung ketidakpastian dalam x dan z untuk state ini dan nilai ekspektasi dari
y dengan state ini kita mendapatkan hasil ini dari Qiskit ketika kita mengambil produk dari dua
ketidakpastian dalam X dan Y kita melihat bahwa seperti yang diharapkan itu lebih besar dari nilai mutlak
dari nilai ekspektasi y tapi ini hanya untuk satu state tertentu kita ingin memastikan pertidaksamaan ini
berlaku untuk semua state qubit jadi mari gunakan estimator lagi tapi kali ini kita akan memintanya untuk memindai melalui nilai-nilai
parameter dan menemukan nilai ekspektasi pada setiap nilai parameter yang kita berikan di sini parameter yang ingin kita
pindai adalah sudut Theta pada bola Bloch sehingga kita memeriksa pertidaksamaan untuk semua state qubit yang terletak pada
busur ini yang memotong bidang XZ ketika kita melakukan ini kita mendapatkan plot sebagai fungsi dari sudut Theta kurva merah
adalah produk dari dua ketidakpastian dan kurva oranye adalah nilai ekspektasi dari y seperti yang diharapkan
produk dari ketidakpastian dalam x dan z jauh lebih tinggi dari nilai ekspektasi y tapi itu
tidak terlalu sulit untuk memenuhi pertidaksamaan karena nilai ekspektasi y sangat rendah yaitu nol untuk semua state pada
busur ini mari lakukan pemindaian serupa melalui nilai-nilai Theta tapi daripada memindai dalam bidang XZ kita akan mengatur phi sama dengan pi/
4 jadi kita melihat state qubit yang terletak pada busur berbeda pada bola di sini kita melihat pertidaksamaan diuji
sedikit lebih banyak karena kurva oranye dan kurva merah lebih dekat bersama tapi merah selalu di atas oranye
dan prinsip ketidakpastian masih berlaku kita belum memeriksa semua state tapi semoga kamu mulai mengerti
idenya ada ketidaktahuan fundamental tentang dua aspek komplementer mana pun dari suatu sistem kuantum
termasuk qubit yang sudah kita gunakan prinsip ketidakpastian memaksa kita untuk menghadapi fakta bahwa betapapun
kerasnya kita mencoba betapapun cerdasnya pengukuran kita kita tidak akan pernah mengetahui segalanya dengan presisi sempurna
tidak ada yang bisa menghindari itu sungguh kalau kamu tidak percaya aku atau bahkan kalau kamu percaya aku aku tantang kamu untuk melihat modul
yang ditautkan di deskripsi dan coba mengalahkan prinsip ketidakpastian terima kasih sudah menonton dan sampai jumpa lain kali